buongiorno a tutti belli e brutti ha
messo il nuovo video di quello youtuber
che racconta sempre icap propri davanti
alla gente ed è poco premi di friendly e
no non è giunto drillo ai ragazzi stiamo
parlando di una situazione che mi è
sempre stata a cuore la mia media
scolastica la mia media scolastica è
sempre stata meraviglie i miei genitori
sono sempre stati fieri di me perché io
a scuola sempre non sempre stato il
numero c'è proprio in classe la gente
copiava da me anche la prof
quando micidiale copiare da me frega
guarda per correggere le capisco cosa
iscritto e poi le correggo l'aspettiamo
di cagate la smettiamo di cagate faceva
cagare però c'erano delle situazioni in
cui mi destreggiava abbastanza bene e
molte volte me la sono cavata oggi vi
racconto una di queste situazioni che
penso sia in classifica la migliore in
realtà credo che non ce ne siano di
migliori di questa andavo fortunatamente
alle medie e quindi alle medie
riceve alle medie è facile non c'è
niente di troppo strano non è vero
faceva cagare anche alle medie
però c'è stato un voto in particolare
che mi ha svoltato l'esistenza adesso ve
lo racconto tiravamo tipo in seconda
media una roba del genere quindi niente
di troppo strano di italiano c'erano i
temi sui libri letti ok quindi tu legge
di un libro e poi facevi un tema
riguardante quel libro ok c'è di pro
facevi il riassunto non lo so ti faccia
delle domande riguardanti quel libro la
verifica di italiano era questa quindi
ragazzi cosa è successo in questa
incredibile verifiche nel suo racconto
grazie mille nel bel tiro prego e di
seconda media avevano portato in classe
uno scatolone gigante con dei libri a
nomi significato informi la premessa
prima
ok allora questa cosa a pedali dico dopo
premessa importantissima io guardavo in
quel periodo i cartoni ma tanti c'è
proprio anche alle medie vorrà un sacco
di gatto infatti avevo la ragazza ma
avevo il cartone ma soprattutto parlava
i cartoni di cartoon network vi piacerà
tantissimo cartoon network e jetix c'era
questo questa cosa in spiaggia questo
programma si chiama jetix che ti faceva
fare ti faceva guardare un sacco di
ignoranti incredibili tra cui i due
fantagenitori chi non ha mai viste le
fantasie di tori
voi non avete mai visto spegnete questo
video però ragazzi a parte questo cosa
molto importante dei due fantagenitori
c'era una puntata dove timi turner che
il protagonista di due fantasisti due
fantagenitori sono tipo come vi spiego
sono delle fate che questo bambino ha a
sua disposizione e esaudiscono i
desideri che questo bambino uomo del
posto bambino dice vuole vincere voglio
vincere la partita di rocket league e la
vince questo bambino che ha dato che mi
turner un bel giorno decide di portare
in vita
tom sawyer kate chi è tom sawyer tom
sawyer e il protagonista di un'opera di
mark twain che è uno scrittore timi
turner deve fare un compito in classe e
deve
leggersi tutto il libro di tom sawyer
siccome non ci ha voglia di farlo che
cosa fa chiave fantasy torrice ragazzi
non c'ho voglia di studiare per questo
compito portatemi in vita tom sawyer il
protagonista del libro che dovrei
leggere che io ci faccio due chiacchiere
e poi faccio i compiti in classe questi
sono sicuro che non lo sbaglio questa
era la trama della puntata quindi loro
portano invita a tom sawyer luigi
chiacchierava del genere non mi dicono
ma va a finire tra questa era la puntata
bene torniamo io alle medie ok
ero un fan ma incredibile dei due
fantasy tria provviste infinite
riportato due fantagenitori erano
rimasti portano su scatole con miliardi
e mezzo di libri e ci dicono cicia prof
sceglietene uno ve lo dovete leggere e
poi tra figlio di [ __ ] e poi tra due
settimane facciamo il compito in classe
quindi voi dovete leggere tutto il libro
e poi vi fanno delle domande scritte qui
nella mosceria il libro dalla legge
arriva su scatolone guardo dentro lo
scatolone c'erano un sacco di libri tra
alcuni più piccoli alcuni più grossi
alcuni mattoni giganti
io per sfizio ma avrebbe solo per sfizio
prendo il mattone gigante solo per
ispezionarlo un attimo prevedere che ha
chiesto fattore leggo il titolo di
stoppatone gigante e indovinate un po
quale dal titolo tom sawyer in un primo
momento ho visto su mazzonetto madonna
che il pirla che svia sta roba
poi leggo il titolo tom sawyer come ho
letto tom sawyer e mi si sono illuminati
gli occhi tantissimo perché ho detto no
va perché questo è il libro di tom
sawyer quello che anche timi turner ha
appreso è fatto il compito in classe
vedo che comunque mio compagno sono ci
sono io se non sa cavare benissimo
leggo tom sawyer gigante lo prendo e
dico è il momento di diventare un uomo
lo prendo e dico proprio scelgo questo è
lei bravo ostuni ha scelto il più grande
e quindi lui è uno che si vuole
impegnare i bellissimi tempi della
scuola proprio mi manca un sacco vado a
casa passano le fatidiche due settimane
secondo voglio quanto letto di quel
libro letto niente
arriva il giorno della verifica riporto
il libro a scuola
a riportarlo sta per iniziare la
verifica io cinque ragazzi cinque minuti
prima della verifica cinque minuti prima
mi mette un attimo così e dico facciamo
una roba siccome non son cup e quindi
adesso in questo momento me l'avrebbero
beatamente nel deretano facciamo che
apre il libro elenco su tre ro ber
ma così proprio a caso apre il libro a
metà a metà room attacco leggo la prima
riga in mezzo tom sawyer aiuto al suo
amico a dipingere la staccionata mi
dicono che ho letto questa cosa
ok chiudo viso verifica va bene a fare
il riassunto del libro io a concentro
tutto il mio essere nel descrivere per
bene come era fatto tom sawyer perché
non sapevo dalla puntata di due
fantagenitori sì perché un mascalzone
che fa determinate cose mi dicono che
non eri non ricava proprio dritto e
viveva sulle rive del mississipi questo
me lo ricordavo sempre per i due
fantagenitori me lo ricordo tuttora dove
va a verona poi una volta ad esempio
aiutato un amico a dipingere una
staccionata volevano scritto delle
cagate inventati sim è invasa l'unica
linea che avevo letto lavoretto solo
quella riga
finisco il tema lo consegno passano due
giorni torna con i temi tutti i corretti
io ragazzi sono l'unico anno presuntivo
7 8 6 e mezzo set
io ho preso nove e mezzo forse perché va
corretta una roba angolo ma preso nove
me a quasi dieci c'è io non ho scritto
niente di tutto quel mattone non l'ho
scritto nulla
nulla però sapevo le robe base tipo e
lui e viene dalle misure dipinge la
staccionata con un suo amico 10 che esse
stata la verifica più rubata del secolo
cia rubata in un amen
veramente non saprei neanche non so
rendono dove vorrei che sarà messo alla
superiore superiori o questa bravata
propaghi grazie ai due fantagenitori che
mia giusta alla vita grazie cosme banda
che mi avete fatto prendere un bel 10
quindi quello che volevo dire che
importa a studiare però l'arguta pagine
la furbizia la scaltrezza delle persone
a volte è molto importante perché vi
districate dai vari ostacoli della vita
e potenti qualche modo
risultati incredibili con il minimo
sforzo questa parte non metterla gianpi
i ragazzi però adesso mi sia piaciuto
spero che siate contenti almeno per me
che una volta nella vita un 9 e mezzo
sorpreso a una quanto e dove spero che
la mia vecchia profon abbia visto questo
video
beh ragazzi
[Musica]